Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to "Greetings".
Now this game was made in the game jam, and it's supposedly spooky,
horror,
really dark an- oooooHHHH-  really dark and gritty.
And exceptionally detailed!
oh my God, this actually looks...
*gazes in aw*
pretty dang good...
I don't know why it's got in store for me, but I'm gonna go charge bravely into the darkness
I just hope for the best.
'Cuz I know...
hellLOOOO??
anybody hoOme???
Anybody want to mess with me?
Hey, hi, how's it going? This seems like a trap!
I'm just going to go ahead and say that now this seems like a trap.
I just get spawned in in the mysterious space station, and I don't know what I'm doing or where I'm going
Seems honestly like a traaap
Where you taking me, where am I?
What in the world is this place? What's still wibble-wobbling in my ears?
Oh.. I don't know. It looks like it's like a level in Doom
Which I wouldn't mind if it out a little bit of doom-esc to it, but I don't think I'm gonna be that lu- haii o.o
Hi, who are you?
What are you doing here?
Why are you here? Nice ass hello, hi, okay. Hey? Hey
okay
*In a human voice* Hey Tom
Hey Greg
*Points with finger and thinks about life*
Are you fucking kidding me??
OHH are you fucking kidding me? That was it?? That was it?
An entire experience just to say hello? OHHHHHh
You sack of shit
OHohoho, you sack of shit. Oh my God this might be the shortest let's play I've ever done in my life
Even video game the game wasn't shorter than this let's play
That's so stupid! Ohh I feel terrible but I gotta admire your charm
Alright, so I couldn't leave you guys with uh such a short let's play so
You're gettin' a double feature today! I've gotten mouse simulator, which is the game that I was like
Ehh I don't know if it'll be good, so I guess
we're gonna find out, ohh man anyway, so the
Let's do this.
my God, oh
My God. Oh this game is atrocious, or I shouldn't be so negative this game is amazing. Oh look cheese??
Oh, I'm not dead. I'm not dead, am I... oh geez oh. Oh. Oh now. I'm dead. Oh no.
ha ha ha ha
The double feature of the shortest let's plays ever. So funny.
Oh my God, that is so funny.
Oh shit. Oh, there's another one right there alright. Let's not do that. I can't jump oh
Oh, that's helpful
oh look at my fuckin face ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
oh man ok oh
Hi
Hello, hi, how's it going? Woo? Oh?
Okay, I'm right here. Hello- OW
*gets stepped on violently*
You evil person, that's horrible
that's horrible,  oh my God
You are horrifying
Okay, well I found all the way to die
Oh. let's try to actually play this
Okay, bye
Hello
Okay
What's with the music?
Why does this game need- why does this game need heavy metal playing in the background?
This isn't Doom. This is a mouse simulator
It's not that intense . (Or is it mark?)
What am I trying to do here? excuse me, uh pardon me. Uh, pardon moi, hi, okay?
Can I sprint, no? I just got to get out of here.
Oh, her looming shadow of death
Alright, I'm just gonna scoot onto here. You can't-
No you don't. You don't see nobody.
Alright- oH that is
Oh, that's downright terrifying
ha ha ha ha ha
Oh my God
That's so scary
Don't please! oh look is that food, oh good. I think-
*Markimoo noises intensifies*
Okay, alright
Is that all I'm supposed to do?
I have to run away- Oh, what's with your chin?
What's going on with your mouth there? Oh?
Is this a dead end? Oh, what's the point of this?
Yeah
Ahh. oh that's no good
*weird animal mating call*
I have- That's awfully mean of you
oh oh ohohohoho
ha ha ha yeah, don't even
Don't even try, it don't even try do it. Uh-oh, I don't know where to go. I think I'm lost
Uh-oh, I might be cornered.
*laughs* Can you not get to me?
Oh, I'm Gonna starve to Death
I have no chance. No joke. I'm gonna die
I'm assuming that's my hunger bar
I have nothing to base that on but the only thing my gamer instinct tells me that is, is hunger
Okay, I'm dead alright. Well, I guess at the end of mouse simulator
See this is why I didn't want to play this one like by itself, but I guess the opportunity presented itself
*laughs some more*
Alright, so anyway that is the end of this two-parter
Mouse Simulator and Greetings
Both amazing games that I love very much, that made me laugh
I mean, I'm not even joking about that
They made me laugh a lot but for different reasons
that I think they intended but either way
Thank you everybody so much for watching hope you enjoy this small double feature even as normal like two games
Still one of the shortest let's plays I've ever done. But hey that's just the way it is so thank you again
Let me know what you thought these game down in the comments below
I'll put links in the description why not and as always I will see you in the next video. Bye. Bye